[Música]
llegamos a la revista de prensa rosa
parece más de esta mañana movida de
jueves sobre todo en el reino unido- y
en europa porque porque pues ya se
conocía entonces de la boca del propio
boris johnson su fin a este cargo de
primer ministro y pues vamos a ver quién
sería el sucesor pero como entonces
señala esto y reseña esta renuncia a las
portadas británicas bueno buenos días
tenemos una larga crónica por delante
porque este es uno de esos momentos no
en que es un bombazo mediático y de
hecho queríamos empezar precisamente por
las portadas británicas en papel que
ayer señala vamos y como bien decías a
conversando con luisa no la corresponsal
en londres esta era una renuncia
anunciada pero no estaba claro cuando
iba a suceder no finalmente cuál iba a
ser el momento ya en que boris johnson
pues no pudiera aguantar más en el cargo
pero precisamente está digamos
indeterminación se refleja muy bien en
las aportadas en papel de los medios
británicos que quedaron desactualizadas
en cuestión de horas no porque
precisamente the times a su edición de
hoy en papel dice johnson pelea por su
vida the daily telegraph herido
mortalmente el primer ministro desafía
al gobierno que le pide que renuncie o
por ejemplo no the bitter en hasta las
últimas consecuencias hasta el final o
hasta la muerte no distintas
traducciones puede tener esta expresión
del general un esperaré por aquí no o
financial times johnson sacudido por una
revuelta interna
eso sí bueno
johnson acaba de anunciar no por su
propia boca como bien decías a su
renuncia pero digamos que ya se esperaba
desde hace unas horas esta mañana ahora
vamos a llegar a esto así es rosa pero
finalmente pues tenían razón porque
luchó por su vida luchó hasta el final
por mantenerse en este cargo de primer
ministro también como lo decía luisa
pulido y como le decía a nuestro
invitado que tuvimos javier pues fue su
sueño de toda la vida que finalmente ya
llegó hasta su final digamos la portada
the economist porque no pierde vigencia
exacto y es que the economist sí que
publicó esta mañana esta portada digamos
un poco paródica vemos aquí esta imagen
que no es verdadera que es verdadera
efectivamente el único montaje que le
hacen los gráfica dores de diego no
mixta es cortar este hilo pero digamos
que johnson siendo alcalde de londres se
quedó colgado en una tirolina no y
estuvo unos cinco minutos colgando del
aire agitando las banderas del reino
unido hasta que lo pudieron a sacar de
ahí y precisamente y economist en lugar
de poner pues de fall down down for no
la caída tiene un título cloud aun no la
caída fuerte del payaso sí bien bien
fuerte bien en todo caso ahora si raúl
vamos a ver ya cómo se han ido
precipitando las cosas en estas últimas
horas guau no está esa portada y de
verdad que impresiona digamos que muchos
británicos como está diciendo lisa
pulido no vi tan bien pues decían los
críticos que era un payaso exactamente y
lo que está claro y ayer digamos que
destacamos el hecho de que gran parte de
la prensa británica pedía abiertamente
la renuncia no de boris johnson pero es
que ya lo que es público y conocido
la revuelta ha sido en el interior de su
propio partido es que ya prensa sociedad
y su propio partido le ha perdido el
respeto incluso líderes también de todo
el mundo el crimen dijo que quería una
persona más competente que estaba feliz
una renuncia de johnson pero vamos al
momento exacto cuando la bebé se anunció
que boris johnson anunció finalmente
esta tan esperada renuncia exactamente
no en esta mañana en el reino unido- la
bbc- la corporación pública de medios
audiovisuales interrumpió su
programación porque su corresponsal en
downing street les anunciaba lo que
decíamos no está renuncia anunciada
veamos
este el primer ministro ha aceptado
dimitir ha hablado con sir graham brady
el presidente del comité de la bancada
1922 esta mañana y ha reconocido que es
apropiado dimitir y que el partido elija
un nuevo líder a tiempo para la
conferencia del partido que es a
principios de octubre
continuamos borrosa con avis y cinco
razones por la caída de johnson las
vamos a repasar brevemente porque ya es
lo que hemos venido comentando toda la
mañana y todos estos días no por un lado
el detonante el caso de crisp interno al
que johnson nombró como jefe de
disciplina de su partido y que luego se
supo que sobre él pesaban denuncias de
abuso sexual recordemos que lo que acabo
de detonar la situación y degradar la
credibilidad de johnson fue que él en un
primer momento cuando se hicieron
públicas estas denuncias dijo que no
sabía nada pero el lunes un alto
funcionario de downing street dijo que
johnson había sido advertido
personalmente de que sobre pitcher
pesaban estas denuncias no y finalmente
cuando este alto funcionario hizo
público pues que johnson conocía de que
se acusaba a este colaborador digamos
que ahí empezaron la cascada de
dimisiones no porque ya pues fue eso no
la gota que colma el vaso respecto a la
credibilidad de johnson ya fuero tentó a
dimisiones rosa efectivamente no claro
un récord histórico por otro lado el
escándalo bueno del partido de estas
fiestas en downing street durante la
pandemia incluido su propio cumpleaños o
una fiesta en víspera del funeral del
príncipe felipe o por otro lado también
el hecho de que a raíz del partido boris
johnson fue multado y aparte a pesar de
que la multa no fue gran cosa en
términos económicos sí que johnson se
convirtió así en el primer ministro del
reino unido- multado moralmente maras
esta multa no exacto y y multado en
ejercicio de sus funciones no bien por
otro lado también señalan el alta de
precios y la inflación que recordemos
esto le a la gestión de esta situación
económica le ha supuesto importantes
discrepancias con crisis una ex ministro
de finanzas que fue quien encabezó justo
junto a javi del ex ministro de salud un
poco toda esta cascada de dimisiones por
otro lado conflictos de intereses
también así como falta de ideas y es que
sus críticos le acusan de que a pesar al
margen del break sheet pues no tenía más
ideas ni más pues eso no un poco de
voluntad para llevar al reino unido
hacia ninguna parte veamos ahora un par
de apuntes de la bbc sobre la reacción a
esta renuncia de johnson rosa si
rápidamente por un lado la corresponsal
en bruselas dice que así que bruselas
está contenta que no apreciaban
especialmente a johnson pero que temen
que llegue alguien peor y como bien
decías moscú también ha mostrado pues su
satisfacción por la renuncia de johnson
por otro lado el periodista político de
un periodista político de la bbc- señala
que boris johnson quiere quedarse hasta
octubre hasta la convención del partido
conservador para intentar arreglar
algunas de las cosas que están sobre la
mesa como el protocolo de irlanda el
hecho que escocia quiere hacer otro
referéndum pues también la inflación o
la cuestión de la guerra en ucrania
vamos ahora con the gardian rosa la
editorial y también un poco cómo iba the
economics porque titula un legado
vergonzoso totalmente dice
sacar al líder no es suficiente para
reparar el daño causado a la democracia
dice fraude es una palabra que puede
describir a una persona y a una acción
al mentiroso ya la mentira boris johnson
es ambas cosas también carga contra los
políticos conservadores que renunciaron
estos días porque dice renunciaron
cuando ya era insalvable la figura de
johnson y un poco anunciaron para no
hundirse con él pero no es nuevo para
nadie que johnson era incapaz de liderar
el ejecutivo británico y dice que su
renuncia pondría fin a una época
destructiva para la democracia pero la
mancha para los tories será difícil de
sacar así es rosa y también hay mucha
información pero no quiero que
destinamos esta revista de prensa sin
hablar del humor británico por supuesto
un humor suspicaz y como entonces lo
titula pues la prensa británica y que
podemos ver no sé si nos trae como
caricaturas viñetas de johnson en esta
renuncia si mira hemos seleccionado la
caricatura de ben sergeant en the
gardian a la que no hacen falta más
palabras y ven james siempre dibuja así
a boris johnson no con este pues culo
por un acto por otro lado tenemos la
ilustración de peter brooks en the times
que vemos ya johnson en la tumba
preguntando puedo quedarme en el papel
de pared porque recordemos la
remodelación de downing street y entre
otro escándalo y por último tenemos aquí
el último corte no vemos ya reino unido-
barriendo este pelo de boris johnson tan
emblemático y reino unido- despidiéndose
de boris johnson vamos a ver lo que
viene ahora raúl el pelo de boris
johnson que pues no veremos más no pues
bueno vamos a ver cuando cuando es el
cargo pero sin duda pues vamos a tener
que despedirnos de este peinado de boris
johnson rosa en todo caso igual
muchísimo gracias entonces por lo que
fue toda esta repaso por la prensa
británica de la renuncia tan esperada de
lo que ha sido entonces
el anuncio del primer ministro británico
visión son por supuesto cerrar con humor
que los británicos y sainc aceleró con
humor para compensar un poco esta
tragedia dentro del partido conservador
porque claro la prensa no tenemos tiempo
de comentarlo todo pero también hace
crónicas de cómo se vivieron estas horas
en downing street boris johnson cargando
contra su partido diciéndoles malditos
yo les gané las elecciones no y
apuntando toda la prensa a que el
partido conservador sea quien sea que lo
lidere así como el ejecutivo británico
seguramente no va a convocar nuevas
elecciones generales porque seguramente
las perderían han dado el nivel de su
imagen sino que van a esperar hasta
finalizar esta legislatura tensión ante
estas últimas horas en el 10 de downing
gracias rosa pasamos a saludar a nuestro
primer invitado el día